morelli bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france pour
revenir sur cette visite du pape
françois cinq ans après celle au camp
des réfugiés de moria le pas françois
est donc retourné 1 sur l'île de lesbos
il s'est dit inquiet du recul de la
démocratie en europe il a appelé on
l'entend du 1 je cite le naufrage de
civilisation c'est une visite très
politique du peuple françois
alors le pen françois contrairement à
ses prédécesseurs et surtout jean paul 2
est un hacker autonome au point de vue
politique n'est pas liée comme l'était
gens plus de à la politique américain
il n'est pas lié non plus à la politique
européenne
on se souvient que nixon et jean-paul
deux très bonnes équipes pour essayer de
déstabiliser la pâleur et lui long qui
dit ce qu'il pense devoir dit en tant
que chef religieux alors moi je suis là
tu es militant mais je le dois saluer
son autonomie et son autonomie lors des
questions aussi délicat que le
désarmement
que la l'accueil des réfugiés où il a
vraiment
stigmatiser l'euro pointe et le haut qui
d'une part un joli discours sur les
valeurs qu'on payait les valeurs de
solidarité
d'accueil et hydra et qui en fait sans
trop de murs et de barbelés pour un pas
que yi he les réfugiés effectivement le
pas françois très quitterie très
critique envers l'europe lilas et
dénoncer le recul de la démocratie
voulait vautier on entend parfois que ce
pape est bien il connaît pas bien
l'europe finalement est-ce que c'est le
cas quelle est sa vision lui de l'europe
eh bien je crois qu'au contraire il a
une vision extrêmement politique de
l'europe
qui est une
monstre aujourd'hui
qui prend des décisions
mais qu'il est prend des décisions qui
sont sans aucun rapport avec ce les
valeurs des classes j'ai trouvé très
fort
son son accent mis sur les lui parce que
quand c'était le mur de berlin 30
hurlait que c'était épouvantable
et aujourd'hui on sent sourcillière du
encore d'être employé des fonds
européens pour faire des murs aux
frontières de la pologne
ou de lure pour protéger le nord de la
méditerranée
alors je crois que c'est la même chose
aussi pour la circulation des personnes
quand il y avait les deux camps est et
ouest
l'europe scandalisé disait enfin laisse
n'accepte pas la circulation des
personnes mais aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
parle de circulation des personnes c'est
surtout empêcher les personnes de
circuler vers le coin au sein de
l'église il ya plusieurs approches sur
la question migratoire on peut citer
celle du cardinal guinéen robert sarah
pour lui le meilleur accueil à offrir
aux migrants c'est d'aider l'afrique
pour que les jeunes puissent y rester au
sein même du vatican la question
migratoire est elle fait débat
aujourd'hui
alors c'est une position très classique
de dire pour qu' il n'y ait plus de
migrant vers nous il faut qu'il y ait
plus déséquilibre fondamental
mais c'est assez piteux piste je dirai
pas ce que il faudra aider toute
l'afrique il faut créer des parties de
l'asie pour que effectivement ces
déséquilibres ne soit plus en vigueur
or ce n'est pas question dead c'est une
question de régime le régime politique
mais surtout économique et les gens sont
maintenus dans la misère à porter régime
épouvantable et donc là la meilleure
chose à faire ce serait d'abattre ces
régies de soutenir sur place des
syndicats demandent et obtiennent des
salaires suffisants et si les gens
avaient sur place un salaire suffisant
et un régime démocratique je pense que
il après et chez eux cette crainte de
chrétiens en europe de voir un jour la
civilisation chrétienne
disparaître complètement cette vision
lui le pape françois il ne la partage
absolument pas
je crois qu'il est la grande différence
entre
des des traditionalistes catholiques
le pas le bomb a véritablement une
vision très ouverte par exemple par
rapport à la chine aussi la vision
ouverte alors que c'est si beaucoup d'un
politisé en une vision véritablement
agressive par rapport à la chine est
pour lui l'important c'est de souffrir
c'est la solidarité c'est de construire
des ponts et c'est bon il a essayé dans
le temps des voyages les construire
aussi avec l'église orthodoxe
parce que on sait que sur le terrain il
y à de véritables rivalité entre
l'église catholique et
que ce soit dans l'ex yougoslavie où que
ce soit dans d'autres pays et pour lui
il faut absolument que le sommet donne
l'exemple l'exemple d'une fraternité
retrouvée entre des frères chrétiens qui
sont divisés pour ce que j'en ai un jour
23 appelait de travail question que plus
personne ne comprend il nous reste
quelques secondes peut-être cette
dernière question vendredi soir on a vu
le pape sortir de son texte il était
même exaspérés il a eu ces mots excusez
moi je voudrais dire que ce que j'ai sur
le coeur est ce que aujourd'hui il a de
plus en plus de mal à se faire entendre
est ce que les mots du pape parviennent
encore à bousculer les consciences des
dirigeants du monde
alors je dirais que
malheureusement il n'a pas l'écoutent
des catholiques pour commencer parce que
si vous faites le compte du nombre de
chefs d'état chefs de gouvernement qui
se prétend quatre lits il devrait
évidemment suivre l'enseignement du pas
mais les catholiques sont plus
prompt à suivre des enseignements
dogmatique que ce soit contre
l'euthanasie ou contre le mariage gay
contre l'avortement plutôt que d'écouter
les paroles du pape qui sont des paroles
de solidarité d'ouverture merci beaucoup
à anne morelli d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes historienne et
spécialisé dans l'histoire des religions